ces lieux c'est dur c'est dur d'avoir un
temps en 2001 c'est tout
à l'hôtel mathis 19 ans et je suis
étudiant respect opératoire aux métiers
du son à chalon sur saône
donc voilà je suis
j'avais pas la rendre réguler
tmx et commencer à se tenir à laguiole
mon prof on travaille sur un groupe que
j'ai enregistrée qui s'appelle giacomo
et en fait là l'idée c'était de
travailler sur ce qu'on appelle le
masters c'est fait on traite
l'intégralité du signal mixer pour que
l'homogénéité sur tout l'album
du coup je vais pouvoir moi j'ai
toujours adoré la musique est en fait je
me suis toujours demandé comment on
faisait pour qu'un album sonne bien
qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient qu'à un
concert on était pris dedans du coup
depuis très jeune j'ai été très
intéressé par ça je trouve quoi qu'y
être base la préparation elle nous
prépare en deux ans à trois concours en
particulier pour entrer dans une école
supérieure je préfèrerais aller au cnsm
conservatoire de paris qui m'intéresse
vraiment dans la formation c'est la
dimension musicien et ingénieur du son
parce que c'est pas seulement le métier
d'ingénieur du son où on pousse les
boutons et voilà d'avoir un regard avisé
sur la lecture d'une partition la
direction d'un artiste ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui m'intéresse
[Musique]
c'est encore trop scolaire ce que je
peux je trouve imagine que tu es en
train de composer ce morceau avait pas
dans ta tête tu cherches tu es nantes
[Musique]
tu fais en est d'une certaine manière je
sais pas comment mais j'ai commencé la
percu vers 6-7 ans c'est toujours
important de rester instrumentistes
parce que ça permet de garder aussi un
regard d'expérience sur les personnes
qu'on enregistre les personnes avec qui
on travaille
puisque avant tout la musique c'est des
instrumentistes puis c'est un plaisir de
la danse
[Musique]
manière générale je dirais que les
prépas sont c'est que du bonheur voilà
parce que bah c'est des gens qui ont
déjà une ouverture d'esprit énorme qui
sont capables d'assimiler beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de chance mon coloc
avec trois étudiants aussi qu'ils sont
dans la préparation avec les temps qui
courent la chance d'être en colloque
parce que quand on rentre on n'est pas
tout seul et la nature gens qui ont ce
problème là d'être isolé c'est quoi le
fait de pouvoir discuter d'avoir
justement d'autres sujets de discussion
que les maths la physique puis même la
musique bat ça me permet aussi de de
relâcher un peu la pression que total on
est à peu près un taux de 52 heures de
cours par semaine
c'est sûr que j'ai tant en temps se
détendre un peu ça fait du bien
la musique c'est une passion elle est
omniprésente dans 5 ou 10 ans j'aimerais
qu'elle fasse par son métier en tout cas
après comment new je me laissais un la
possibilité de découvrir encore des
choses à apprendre